now this is something you should be
proud of it's hard to learn JavaScript
but it's even harder to learn it well
then you may still feel a little bit
shaky around implementing things like
this but that's completely normal so I'm
going to give you a few other ideas on
how to change your to do application
because although it's cliched to say
practice does make perfect here are some
things that you can add to the to-do
application let the user set the
priority status when they're creating
the to-do item let users filter or sort
by that same priority status expand the
priority status feature to have more
than two levels right now it's either
priority or not priority what if there
were different levels of priority
priority one two and three what about
adding a recycle bin for recovering
deleted to dues you could add colors so
that way people using your application
can associate different to dues with
each other by using colors you could add
a whole labeling system for sorting and
filtering and those are only the ideas
that I came up with
there are tons more things that you can
do with this particular application some
of these are fairly trivial to implement
and some of them are quite a bit more
work and here's the best part if you
make any of these changes or any others
there'll be your changes you will also
be making whatever CSS changes are
necessary and that is exciting you're
finally at the point where you can do
this stuff completely on your own so
here's my challenge to you try it
if you're feeling hesitation or
trepidation go ahead and change your
attitude from oh I don't know if I can
do that - I know I can do that myself it
might just take me a little bit of time
or I may need to do some research and
that right there that change is the
hardest part it's changing your mind
you're not grappling with the code or
the technical problem you're grappling
with yourself so take your hesitation
throw it out the window and do it start
on the project start solving the problem
now here are two things that have worked
for me that I'd like to share with you
the first is to be a detective remember
that in the world of computer
programming there is no magic at all so
any code that you have and any problems
that you have are discoverable and
understandable you can go in and you can
change things you can change the way
they work and you can fix them
so remember that there's no magic the
second thing is I'd like you to write
code every day that's a challenge John
Resig the original author of jQuery
wrote the feeling of making progress is
just as important as making actual
progress so I'd like you to add this to
your calendar every single day make
yourself a notification or a reminder to
write some code so congratulations
you've made it through this course but
don't let it stop here keep the momentum
up keep building things and reading and
learning and exploring and as you build
cool things go ahead and share them on
the Udacity forums because it's always
good for other students to see what
you've been building for you to see what
they've been building and we always love
seeing what you guys build keep it up
good work and have fun we'll see you
later